we're going to be talking about this uh
liar uh Brian Johnson also known as
liver King uh he was exposed by the delt
King Derek from more place more dates
um word on the street by the way is that
the
guy that he was emailing because the
form apparently is used uh consistently
with all his uh coaching clients uh
the guy behind his protocol was vigorous
Steve
um we'll find out though apparently
there's there's more to come on it but
Vigor Steve's a solid dude he's open and
honest about his ped use he lives in
Thailand it's legal there you can buy
whatever you want
um and he's super knowledgeable his
channel is useful in that area I've had
him on a plane to win podcast maybe
about a year year and a half ago
um you should go check him out subscribe
to his channel as well but purportedly
um yeah he was The Mastermind behind
this guy's uh cycle but again I guess
we'll I guess we'll find out the reality
of this so if you guys don't know who
this liver King clown is uh is this dude
over here and I have no problems you
know if you're going to use Peds like
you know this is the kind of stuff that
he would do he would just cruise around
on videos throwing around weights
pulling stuff around I think this is in
either Dubai or Saudi Arabia
he's been traveling around a lot
where's this goofy hat over here
and eats uh Raw Liver balls uh testicles
all kinds of organ meat and he also has
a supplement line which
um which was a big part of the reason
why he was this this guy over here doing
podcasts like he went on a lot of
podcasts I'm going to talk about that in
a little bit but
um he made an apology recently because
he you really didn't have a choice he
had to acknowledge it like there was no
way that this was going to go away
um the expose was just brutal there was
an hour-long expose on this on this guy
um on what he was taking and why he was
taking it uh let me just pull up the
breakdown actually because I have it
here on my Twitter feed
um here we go it's it's going to be a
little hard for you guys to see this but
you know this guy was going around
basically saying I'm Natty I'm Natty
people ask him continuously and he kept
denying it having taken the stuff won't
take the stuff won't ever take the stuff
blah blah blah so this is a leaked email
and he's talking about something around
I think it was 11 to 15 000 a month in
human growth hormone he was taken
um a few other peptides which
um supplement muscle growth recovery uh
growth hormone production all sort of
stuff but the main ones it looks like he
was taking uh were testosterone
sepionate uh decadura Ballin which is
neanderlon and Winstrol
um these are the ones in this email
apparently there's more emails to come
out that have been leaked
um test sip is a bio-identical hormone
uh it's what I take on therapeutic
testosterone replacement actually mine's
an ethianate which is a slightly
different Ester
um but I think I did the math wrong on
his dosages because when I put it out on
Twitter
I had to convert uh cc to
um IUS which is what I use because I use
a
um insulin syringe and I've been honest
about it since day one you go back on my
channel there's a video from like
probably when I was 42 43 when I first
started using it and I did kind of like
a little bit of a breakdown here's you
know here's what it feels like this is
what you know it's been like and it's
truthfully it's great you know if you're
using therapeutic testosterone on the
top of your levels so you can feel good
and operate and have motivation to drive
and all sort of stuff it works I've been
honest about it for years I've never
lied and that's that's just who I am I'm
not that guy by the way Shilling and
lies to sell stuff is not new I mean
I think I've told the story before on
some business classes and maybe
um in some other interviews but one of
the things that I had to deal with back
in my debt business back in those days I
think um I think there was a time when I
was I was definitely in my truck in the
grocery store parking lot my daughter
was in the backseat she was Tiny at the
time and my ex-wife had to run and pick
something up and I was sitting there and
I was just you know I had the window
down it was a hot hot summer day and I
was listening to this contractor beside
me because he had his windows down he
was playing you know the radio and this
radio ad came on of this company that
made these outlandish claims you know
very similar to you know I don't take
the stuff I don't use the stuff I'm all
Natty buy my supplement sort of you know
sort of thing the stuff that you know
the liver King was talking about
and you know like these these companies
will purport great feats without telling
you that you know the truth and they
made these big promises like there's new
there's brand new government programs
that will help you get out of debt it's
all on board you know the government's
approved it you know so sign up now and
people sign up in droves they fell for
that crap immediately and very very
quickly and
these like grifting Shilling lies are in
all Industries it's even in the Mana
swap I'm going to talk a little about a
little bit about that later on because
there's other guys in the fitness
industry that have been pulling his
[ __ ] as well which which kind of
bugged me which I wanted to tie into
this uh as well um you know guys like
Mike O'Hearn Dwayne The Rock Johnson and
um even Chris Hemsworth um there's a few
stories that I want to tell there as
well too but like grifting and lying to
sell [ __ ] is pretty common it's the
easiest well it's the easiest way to do
it and this guy came around and uh
came out of nowhere
uh let me just pull up the next tab over
here
to
he started with these nine ancestral
tenants which I'm gonna get into a
little bit because I think some of them
are actually not too bad to be honest
with you actually yeah let's do that
right now let's throw up these nine
ancestral tenants of the liver King
of heavy does this [ __ ] right
um so I think most of these are pretty
reasonable and on board I've probably
talked about like sleep I mean I did an
entire podcast on everything I've
learned about improving your sleep the
first tenant is sleep because it trumps
everything else and when time and body
brain detox recovery build restore blah
blah blah uh okay fine you know
like you put this like list together of
like things to sort of pump right eat
well of course you gotta eat if you
don't eat you're gonna freaking die
right uh but he's talking about not
eating processed foods okay you know
this Echoes stuff every guy in the
fitness industry have said I mean I've
talked about you know not not eating
[ __ ] before pretty common agree with
that move yeah don't sit in your ass all
day move around you know move more eat
better first thing I tell somebody when
they're like I'm fat and I don't know
how to lose the weight move more eat
better it's not complicated right
um move anyway okay so I agree with that
Shield what does this mean the force
ancestral tenant is Shield because we
need to avoid dangers like our early
ancestors did but instead of running
from see this is how we kind of ties it
into his [ __ ] supplement line with
the desecrated uh organs and all that
sort of stuff because nobody's gonna go
out and eat raw liver right like I think
it's kind of understood nobody's going
to be eating like bone marrow and Oliver
and brains and balls and all that kind
of stuff
so he has to have these tenants to sort
of tie it all into so it's a very clever
marketing scene it's it's a it's a very
very smart and well orchestrated
marketing screen
um in the video that Derek did he was
showing up on the screen the emails that
this guy Brian was sending to his
um I'm just gonna call him the Bro
Science Guy we don't know who who he is
right now uh but Senator the Bro Science
Guy and he's like I've planned on
blowing this thing up I have a social
media team I'm going to grow my
following I think he said something to
like a million six in like a year I'm
gonna do all of these things and I need
to look jacked as [ __ ] right because he
knew he wasn't going to take it popping
his pills so he had this I'm going to
show you livers and balls and spleens
hearts all these raw meats I'm going to
look Jack there's as hell and then for
those people that aren't going to go and
eat all this stuff but they're going to
buy the supplements so the entire
ecosystem was built and one of the
things he needed to tie into it was a
whole nine ancestral tendons so Shield
is the next one the fourth tenant Shield
because we need to avoid dangers like
our early ancestors but instead running
from lines nowaday we run from seed oils
excessive Wi-Fi emaps mad made poisons
I agree you know I've said don't keep
your cell phone in your pocket like
that's the stupidest thing you can do
it's bad for your nuts it disrupts the
mitochondria
connect uh our early ancestor constant
contact with the Earth uh this is like
grounding walking around Barefoot
barefoot shoes
um
agree with it so you know like one two
three
we're on the fifth one and I'm not
disagreeing with anything cold
uh the sixth ancestors would get cold
I mean okay what happens if you live you
know
within the tropics close to the equator
I'm pretty sure our ancestors weren't
able to get cold at any time in their
history so you know now we're starting
to get into more of the Bro sign stuff
and cold immersion does work like
uh Andrew huberman has talked in many
podcasts about you know if you do do a
hot cold immersion sequence
um you'll have elevated dopamine levels
for like hours I think he says like
three or four hours and I've done this
from time to time if I want a productive
day it's a little bit of a pain in the
ass because you got to heat up the song
and then you gotta pull like ice in the
freaking bathtub and do a cold plunge
just you have to sit there for basically
as long as you can but the science
behind it is actually true from what I
understand you know with the huberman
podcast basically your dopamine levels
rise to the same like it competes with
cocaine basically is what he was saying
except for it it lasts a lot longer so
cold immersion is good for you so I'm
not going to argue that uh Sun yeah get
out in the sun
vitamin D producing body from midday sun
exposure works now you got to be careful
with it like he's he's pretty dark
skinned uh I'm guessing he probably took
like peptides like melanatan II
um it can be very effective you got to
be very careful with though you have to
basically microdose it
um has all kinds of side effects like
nausea and if you over overdo it
um there can be complications with uh
Cancer all these stories on it you can
watch some videos uh Leo and Longevity
talks about in details you know when he
gets into stuff like that but uh yeah
you know I would agree with that get out
in the sun especially in the morning and
in the evening again huberman talks
about this you want to get sun on your
like into your eyes the oldest cells in
your eyes are not for vision they're to
reset your circadian rhythm
um so you're supposed to look in you
know directly into the area that the
sun's out in the morning even through
the clouds apparently works later on in
the day I get out in the sun a lot you
guys will notice from my videos I mean
if you go back to the summertime if
it's if it's a nice day I'm out on the
boat or I'm out riding my bike out in
the sun I very rarely use sunscreen
because I want you know direct sun on my
body so I agree with it I mean I don't
disagree with much that I've seen over
here so far son so what's the next one
fight
involve fighting hiding hunting
protecting struggling you know yes sorry
that's right okay there's nothing in
here I don't fight yeah you know
you have to you have to challenge
yourself Bond nine tenant is Bond
long for far it's kind of like love you
know connect uh
okay I mean
there's not much here that I disagree
with okay so you know nine ancestral
tenants were a good idea so he's got
tenants then he's got raw food and then
for those of you that aren't going to go
for the raw food then you've got his
supplement line and he has several
actually
um
we got here we got
this is one of his companies heart and
soil the most nutrient-rich supplement
on the planet
and
it looks like they're in glass bottles
which is impressive actually
um because I've talked about that in the
past I mean you don't want to buy cheap
plastic bottled supplements and hard
capsules so it's probably a quality
product
uh what is this Nature's multivitamin
spark your weight loss what is in this
so this has got organ so it's basically
desecrated organ
and
why doesn't it tell you what the
ingredients are
uh that's strange usually it has
label ingredients somewhere on the
freaking page
usually has pictures of the labels that
you can zoom in on okay there's this
so it's got heart and liver
doesn't tell you how much
of anything else is in there just tells
you there's a few a few grams that's
interesting okay so he's got a heart and
liver product
he's got a protein product here which is
a whole Feast which is basically beef
protein
which is great I mean like I get my beef
protein line from Sweden this is also
from Sweden as well so it's probably a
good product
uh and grass-fed collagens and it's so
ancestral supplements the other one now
in the emails that were leaked he talked
about running a supplement company and
then his next strategy was to sort of
blow it up and he needed to look good
get down to single digit body fat he was
talking about body fat in his back and
his lower
ab area so people have said this guy had
AB implants I don't know I mean AB
implants absculpting absculptings when
they kind of go in and they sort of like
remove fat from between
um you know those uh packs you know the
six-packed APAC you know whatever it is
um so they sort of sculpt out you know
the shape of it a little bit who the
[ __ ] knows I mean you know this guy's
lied lied about his entire image hey
guys I really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism some fat
burning your foundational Essentials for
health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out